so you can see they have a control
system for the air bearing in a
dust-free room in Oxfordshire they're
designing a garbage truck for the
heavens six Decades of the Space Race
have left more than 9 000 tons of debris
in orbit and the risk is growing of a
catastrophic collision with critical
satellites or even astronauts
Astro scale is one of two companies
competing for a UK government-funded
mission to grab two defunct spacecraft
and drag them down into the atmosphere
where they'll burn up if we don't deal
with this problem now we're just going
to have a bigger problem in future so I
think there's a realization that as more
more satellites launch and there's more
collisions and more debris if we don't
start clearing this up we're going to
have trouble
space debris is a nightmare there are
more than one million pieces of space
junk larger than a centimeter across
from rocket parts to tools dropped by
astronauts they're moving at 18 000
miles an hour ten times the speed of a
bullet that's so fast that even a Fleck
of paint can chip the windows of the
International Space Station which has to
Swerve large pieces of junk every few
months and with at least 2 000 new
satellites a year being launched space
is just getting more crowded and
hazardous
but catching a tumbling satellite has
never been done before astroscale is
planning to use a robotic arm its
competitor clear space is going in with
a bear hug in the hope that the target
can't slip away Ground Control would be
too slow to react so the capture will be
completely automated these objects some
of them have been in space for for tens
of years we we don't really know what
condition they're in maybe they're very
brittle or maybe they have things
hanging off them that we have to deal
with and even some of these satellites
we think are dead maybe maybe they're
not quite dead and we'll we'll object as
soon as you start to try and push them
around
there's growing pressure on countries
and companies responsible for the junk
to pay for the cleanup that's an
opportunity for a new industry and the
UK space agency wants to give it liftoff
we've got a track record of success in
developing satellites here and we've got
a world respected space industry and so
building on that we're taking on more
and more ambitious challenges and
obviously that creates jobs in the UK
which is exactly what we want to do
Britain builds more satellites than
anywhere outside California with a
rocket soon to be launched from Europe's
first Spaceport in Cornwall and a
leading role in the orbital cleanup the
UK is very much part of the new space
race Thomas More Sky News